for me I would say at a time where I
could have really done everything and
posted 24 7 and I instead took a step
back and stopped posting as much and I
think that was a good thing because now
I am getting back into it and I'm not
feeling burnt out and I'm feeling
excited to make content again and even
though that might have hurt me then this
is going to help me in the long run
because I'll be able to make content for
longer and do the dances and do all the
fun stuff and make videos with my
friends but it took that little bit for
me to then be able to do this for years
and years and years one thing that
people forget about in my career is I
made content every day five days a week
doing the wine show for five years
Monday through Friday and then when I
got serious about vaynermedia I barely
made content from 2011 to 2014 because I
was fully operating and I remember when
I started back up and did the askgaryvee
show how pumped I was to do it and how
much I dragged the last 100 episodes of
blind Library TV you need to either take
a break or change up what you're making